session
it's a great pleasure to introduce
richard sunworth who
is one of the few speakers here who is
neither a student or a postdoc of peter
beckham
but
has become a
good friend over the years and shares
many of the same research interests and
many people in this room
and today he'll talk about optimal
non-prometric testing of missing
completely at random
okay thank you very much lisa um
thank you to all the organizers actually
for putting together such a fantastic
program um
it's really such a pleasure to be able
to travel again and see people in in
person i've really enjoyed the week
okay so i'm going to speak about uh some
very recent work it's sort of hot off
the press uh it's quite a new topic for
me
um and it's one that i think i've had a
lot of fun working on uh it's all joint
work with a fantastic former phd student
and postdoc of mine tom barrett
uh tom spent a year in france and he's
now
an assistant professor at
the university of warwick
okay so
let's start with why should we care
about missing data
these days um
after all fischer didn't right so
cheers ronald you know that's very
helpful
um
but you know now we're in the the big
data era as the title of this workshop
says
surely it shouldn't matter too much if
uh
uh
some of our data is missing right so
i want to try to give a very toy example
uh to explain why i think actually
missing data is uh even more important
these days than it ever has been
so let's just imagine um a very simple
situation where you've got an n by d
data matrix
and you want to do the most
basic thing the simplest thing you could
possibly do with
missing data which is where you just
ignore
uh you remove any cases where you've got
any any missingness okay complete case
analysis
and we're going to observe every entry
of this data matrix independently with
probability 99 so high probability of
observing every entry
and so if you're in a kind of
20th century situation where you've just
got five variables this isn't too bad
because you get to keep 95 percent of
your observations roughly okay but
actually as soon as you get up to only
300 variables then of course you're
you're going to keep
many few of your observations in fact
only around five percent that's
disastrous so
all of a sudden we really have to think
about what we're going to do about our
missing data
in fact i think i'd like to argue that
missingness
uh in my experience of
applied work is
really represents one of the most
important gaps between
theory uh and practice at the sort of
the people who come along to me with
data and the the sort of models that we
study
in uh
hypothesize in theoretical work i think
we typically don't think about
missingness
when we do this and yet it's uh
it's something that practitioners have
to deal with all the time and it's sort
of even worse than other forms of model
misspecification
in a certain sense you know it can give
unreliable conclusions but actually
often you just you just can't run your
algorithm until you've worked out what
you're going to do
about the missing data okay so it's
complete completely inapplicable
of course uh what you need to understand
about missing data is that the
missingness mechanism so it was a a
cartoon that i liked
to explain that the different sorts of
uh missingness mechanisms that you can
have
uh so we're talking about dog seeking
homework
uh and the the kind of the simplest
situation is that a a dog uh eats a
homework completely at random it doesn't
doesn't know whether a person's a
student doesn't know how good the
homework is
um
that's the kind of ideal situation that
the next situation is where the the
probability that the dog eats your
homework
apparently depends on whether you're a
student or not okay so
um
that's actually not too bad in practice
i mean you you could
you could report if you're interested in
the kind of average score uh on this
homework you could report the average
score for the students and the average
score for for the non-students and and
that wouldn't be uh too much of a
problem
uh but the really problematic situation
is where the dogs eat bad homework right
then
then you're going to get very biased uh
estimates if you try to estimate the
the standard of your students based on
on this
okay this is not my cartoon uh we're not
going to be uh thinking about missing at
random in in this talk we're really
thinking about missing completely at
random
uh and
if this uh situation holds life is
definitely much easier and there has
been quite a lot of work in recent years
studying a lot of contemporary
statistical problems under an mcir
hypothesis
various people in this room have been
involved in some of that work and i've
also
done
a few things in this direction
good
okay so uh here's the setting we're
going to think about
we've got um data that that takes values
in a product space i'll call that uh
d dimensional product space curly x
and i've got a vector that i think of as
a revelation vector it's a binary vector
and uh it just tells me whether the
corresponding component of x is observed
or not so i don't get to see the x i get
to see this
this vector x circ omega
as i uh write it here um that takes
values in this augmented product space
where the the star in is a possible
value for each component and the star
just means you don't observe that
component okay so and and the the omega
the revelation vector is telling me
whether i observe that the uh component
or don't observe that component
so
uh we've got to imagine a situation
where we observe independent copies of
of this random vector we don't get to
see the x individually we only get to
see it's this kind of um
we call a hadamard product
with omega
and
the mtir null hypothesis is that the x
and the omega are independent so
i want to think of this as an
independence test but it's an
independence test where i don't get to
observe the the the x's but
not all of the axes
okay so um
the i'm going to have a little bit of
notation this blackboard bold s
is the set of possible observation
patterns the things that i can observe
simultaneously with positive probability
and then ps is going to denote the
distribution of the this s subset of of
my variables conditional on on those
being the ones that i that i actually
saw okay i put all those uh
distributions together with a p
blackboard bold yes i've got this family
of distributions p blackboard bold s
so a little bit of history and existing
work
um
so
as you might expect a lot of uh
existing work is really in in the
context of parametric models so for
instance if you've got gaussian
observations
where you will observe all pairs of
variables together then you can use an
em algorithm uh to find the mles or the
population mean and covariance matrix
uh so this is done in a paper of little
it's it's a five page paper with about
seven thousand citations now
um
and so you can compare the mean within
each observation pattern to uh the
respective uh
element that you get from this this
null model from the em algorithm
um and and you can construct this uh
chi-squared sort of statistic
um
[Music]
so this is working under the gaussianity
assumption and it's also
just checking for it for a difference in
means across the different
observation patterns okay
more of a discrete test is is fox's test
and that relies on having
complete cases so you can think of that
as having the set one up to d being one
of my possible observation patterns here
then again you can use an em algorithm
to find the mle of the population
distribution and constructor likelihood
ratio style statistic and this is the
formula that i've taken from the paper
for a kind of a three-way
contingency table and you can compare
this to a chi-squared statistic again
another related uh question
is about consistency it's not not the
same as
the mtar hypothesis but
it's sort of related so if i've got two
elements my possible observation
patterns with non-empty intersection
i can think about marginalizing their
respective distributions to the
intersection that this s1 intersect s2
so this would then be a marginal
distribution of this quantity
on this reduced space or on this
intersection
and we'll say that that the family of
distributions this p blackball bold s is
consistent so this is nothing to do with
kind of asymptotics and get uh probably
being bigger bigger than cylon going to
zero anything like it's a different use
of the same word
uh i say it's this family is consistent
if
for each pair of possible uh
elements of my observation patterns when
i marginalize i get the same marginal
distribution okay so
um
in this in this uh
situation here i've got five different
variables i get to observe these uh
these bivariate uh distributions here
but maybe there's one where where i can
see that when i marginalize the the one
two distribution just on the first
variable i get something different from
the one one five distribution
and so you can definitely rule out the
mcar hypothesis if if uh if you don't
have consistency in in this
sense
and so what that motivates you to do is
to construct several two-sample tests uh
of whether or not these distributions
are equal and then you can uh just go
ahead in a fairly standard kind of way
you've got to control for the
the multiple comparisons that you're
doing okay
but actually consistency turns out to be
uh not quite what we're wanting to test
here we're trying to test mcar
and there are certainly non-mcar
settings uh where all consistency tests
would have no power okay so here's a
situation where i've got three bivariate
margin like three three variables and i
get to observe the bivariate marginals
this is going to be like the simplest um
canonical example in in this talk
uh of three bivariate marginals on three
variables so in this case
uh each of the univariate marginals is a
standard gaussian so if i was just
looking at testing consistency then on
the population level these are all
consistent okay
but then i've got a correlation
different correlations between the
the pairs and you can sort of see that
if x2 and x3 is sufficiently highly
positively correlated and x1 and x3 are
sufficiently highly positively
correlated it can't be the case that x1
and x2 are very negatively correlated
i mean if you tried to think what the
covariance matrix would have to be it
would have a negative either value
so so uh that that's that's not possible
so we actually we can we can rule out uh
having mcar in this model if if the
correlation is bigger than a half
so uh
we're going to do various things today
that there are some theoretical
contributions but i just want to
emphasize what we're going to aim to do
from a methodological perspective
here we're going to look for tests of
the mtar hypothesis that don't rely on
parametric assumptions
and that you can use for any kind of
possible
set of observation patterns without the
need for either complete cases or being
able to observe all pairs of variables
simultaneously
and we want these uh these tests to have
power against all detectable
alternatives so what do i mean by
detectable alternatives well actually if
you think about it for a little bit you
realize that there are some non-mcr
settings that you you could never hope
to detect so so here's here's one i've
got a standard gaussian observation and
i only observe it if it's positive okay
if it's non-negative so
that's definitely not an mcar setting
because the omega is is depends on on
the x okay
um but what i would observe the x circ
omega would have the same distribution
as a situation where i just observe a
folded normal distribution and the
absolute value of a standard normal
distribution and i just observe it in an
mcar fashion with probably a half right
so there's no way i can tell on the
basis of my observed data which of those
situations uh was was true
and so i cannot rule out uh the null
hypothesis so
um it turns out that the the kind of the
right thing to test is compatibility so
let me explain what i mean by
compatibility
i've got this these family of
distributions these
ps's and i say they're compatible if
there exists a joint distribution on the
whole product space
whose marginal distribution uh on the
reduced space xs is ps
for each s
okay
so uh for instance if if i only get to
observe each singleton variable
then it's kind of clear that uh that
would be compatible because the joint
distribution it could just take to be
the product the product measure of these
univariate margins right that would be
a joint distribution on the product
space
who whose univariate marginals agreed
with what what i get to see
if i get complete cases
uh then compatibility is equivalent to
consistent
consistency and in fact
uh even slightly more generally uh if if
this family is decomposable uh in the
terminology of lawrence and
spiegelhalter then compatibility is the
same as consistency
but for instance in in this simple
example of three by variant marginals
we've seen
already with the gaussian example that
consistency is not sufficient for
compatibility okay
okay so curly ps0 is going to be denote
the set of compatible uh families of
distributions that i can that i can
right so
if we're
on the null hypothesis for my x and my
omega independent
then the distribution of xs is
unaffected by whether i condition on the
omega because the x and the omega are
independent and i that was what i i call
ps
okay so xs has got distribution ps for
each s
and that means that the distribution of
x is is compatible
conversely if i'm compatible
then i know that i can find a joint
distribution on the whole product space
for which
which marginalizes in the correct way
and if i choose an x tilde that's
independent of the x and the omega
having this distribution
then what i would actually see would
have the same distribution uh as as my
data okay so in other words and of
course the x and the omega are are
independent so they satisfy the the
children in the army are independent so
they satisfy the null hypothesis so i
can't rule out
mcar
uh if i start with a compatible
distribution
so here's the the picture
then um i've got this null hypothesis i
want the test of mcar
but then i've got all the compatible
alternatives and and they're
undetectable
okay so the best i can hope to do is to
test uh compatibility
and then one question is well
if i'm incompatible then can i detect
that that uh
the mtar hypothesis doesn't hold okay so
that's a question we're gonna try and
answer now
any questions so far
okay i want to very slightly change
my model instead of having
independent pairs i'm um you know
analogous to the distinction between
classification problems and discriminant
analysis i'm going to have fixed sample
size from each of my observation
patterns now so uh
for different s's i get to see ns uh
observations all independent
observations okay so now i can think of
these ps's as marginal distributions
and i've got potentially different
sample sizes for the different
observation patterns
and
now we're going to think about testing
compatibility
so
uh it turns out that this is something
that gets thought about in quite a wide
variety of different areas
and one of them is is quantum
contextuality so
uh
so measurement so this is the idea that
measurements of quantum observables
cannot simply be thought of as revealing
pre-existing values so in fact any
attempt to do so with with the kind of
hidden state uh variables
would lead you to a situation where
uh your observed values depended on what
other observables you measure at the
same time this is a sort of quantum uh
phenomenon
uh so contextuality
uh is is a kind of buzzword uh in in in
the quantum area and uh so uh this guy
samson abramsky who's a computer
scientist at oxford has kind of
appreciated that
contextuality arrives when
arises when um you can have observations
empirical data that are locally
consistent but not globally consistent
so the analogy is with this sort of
escher type of print where locally
everything
looks fine until you realize that these
kind of uh these paving slabs are all
going downwards and yet the water's uh
falling in this direction so on the
global level uh i think things aren't
consistent here
um
lots of different areas where these
sorts of uh questions arise
okay so the starting point for our work
is really going to be um uh
a characterization of keller as an old
color characterization from 1984 that uh
says precisely uh that gives a necessary
and sufficient condition for
compatibility so uh i'm going to write g
blackball bold s for a set of sequences
of functions each each individual
function is a function uh on the the
set of values that might uh for the s
observations
they're bounded below by minus one can
be uh um
i don't have a kind of fixed upper limit
although i could actually take it to be
the cardinality of blackboard s minus
one
i want to think of the bounded and upper
semi-continuous
and then i've got a subset of that sort
of functions
where um for every
uh x and x
uh what at least when i sum out uh the
fs is at xs i get something that's
that's non-negative so i can have
positive negative contributions but but
the sum overall should should be
non-negative here
and keller says that the distribution is
compatible if and only if
uh the the sum of these integrals is
non-negative for every fs in this set of
curly gs plus so this is
uh this is actually
you might recognize as a kind of
potentially infinite dimensional
generalization of farcas's lemma
so farkas is lemma
perhaps i won't say now i can say more
about that later uh is is something that
underpins the theory of linear
programming
okay so this gives you a necessary and
sufficient condition and
one of the kind of key contributions i
think of what tom and i did is to try to
quantify to come up with a
quantification or or a measure of
incompatibility via an incompatibility
index
so this instead of just having a binary
are you compatible or not this is
measuring how incompatible you are
um and what we do is we take that
something like the objective function
from
uh from from this guy here and we just
multiply it by minus one over the
cardinality of blackboard bold s and we
take this this supremum over uh gs plus
and that's going to be our our measure
of incompatibility so why does this make
sense
well because i can just always choose a
sequence of functions uh that that are
all identically zero
uh that's a feasible
function here choice and and that would
give me an output of zero here so the
sub must be at least zero right so so
this measure of incompatibility is
non-negative and what the killer
characterization tells me
is that it's equal to zero if and only
if i'm compatible
okay
so it sort of makes sense from that
point of view and actually moreover
because each fs
uh can can only take go down to minus
one uh the the largest this
incompatibility index can be is one so
i've got something that's uh a measure
between zero and one of how incompatible
incompatible this this family is
so this is somehow going to be a
to kind of leap ahead of it this is
going to um control the power of any
test that i might be able to construct
so there's a dual representation of this
incompatibility index that holds quite
generally
when each underlying space is a locally
compact house still space
uh then you can represent this this
incompatibility index in in this way
here so it's like the smallest epsilon
for which you can
write this family as one minus epsilon
times a compatible family plus epsilon
times a a general uh family with with
with on with no restrictions right so
you want to put as much mass as you can
in in the compatible uh
class
so you kind of have to dust off your
topology textbooks that are getting
dusty on your shelf to to prove this why
do you think about locally compact
household spaces well it actually uses
the idea of one point compactification
alexander of compactification that's uh
it's a you're probably familiar with
stereographic projection where you think
about the plane and the map from the on
on the unit sphere and you add this
point at the north pole to make
everything nicely compact and so that
allows you to reduce this situation to a
compact uh situation and then you can
use the the wrist representation theorem
to get this result
okay so um
in the discrete world we can actually
interpret what it means to uh
this sort of
have rfs being one or equivalently you
you can say it's strictly less than one
if and only if i can find a point in my
joint space
which has got positive probability under
each of my possible distributions pps
so
the quantum mechanism don't
don't know about this measure rfps yet
unless they're monitoring the archive
very closely
but they do call that they say if the
complement of this condition they would
call it being strongly contextual
okay so now i want to think about how we
can test
for compatibility
um
and
so this gs in the discrete case yeah i
should emphasize that what i'm going to
talk about now for a while is going to
be focused on the discrete setting
uh this family gs i can then identify
with this uh minus one infinity to the
curly xs so this is a kind of strange
index that is doubly indexed by the s
and and the excess uh within within that
pattern and gs plus is like a convex
polyhedral subset of this set
and then
i'm just optimizing a linear uh
functional over this convex polyhedral
set so i can compute this pretty
efficiently using linear programming
techniques
and so what that motivates me to do is
just compute the the corresponding
sequence of empirical distributions and
use as my test statistic the
incompatibility index evaluated at the
sequence of empirical distributions okay
it's the the obvious plug-in estimator
uh of the
incompatibility index
so
uh as a first stab a a test of of
compatibility then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to reject the null
hypothesis if this r hat is sufficiently
large and this is what i mean by
sufficiently large so it's a little bit
um
a little bit complicated but not too bad
you you know everything you need to know
for for this uh to apply this test right
you know the the level that you're
willing to test out you know the sample
sizes and you should know the
cardinality of the sets that each
variable can take values in
and here is the the the justification uh
for this test then if you give me uh an
alpha which is going to be the
significance level of the test and a
beta which is a desired uh bound on the
type two error probability
then first of all i control the the type
1 error
so if i am compatible then the
probability i reject the null is at most
alpha
but moreover
if i'm sufficiently incompatible by
which i mean that the incompatibility
index is greater than or equal to c
alpha plus c beta then i've got power at
least one minus beta for this test
and since the these this c alpha is
tending to zero as the sample sizes go
to infinity that certainly means that
you know um i would be
i can use the word consistent
which i mean in the context here of
consistency of a test uh i that the test
would be consistent against all fixed
alternatives
so i can now remove the question mark
from my picture here if i'm incompatible
that then then this is detectable
okay so
i i now want to think about how we might
try and improve uh this test somewhat
um and that requires a kind of greater
understanding of the geometry of of
what's going on here so um i can think
of the null space the set of compatible
distributions families of distribution
as a convex whole of the columns of this
a matrix
this a matrix has got
cardinality of s are ones in each column
um one for each uh
entry here
um
and
one thing that slightly distinguishes
this this problem from a testing
perspective from standard hypothesis
testing
is that the set of compatible
distributions is actually a full
dimensional subset of the set of
consistent
distributions consistent sequences so
actually it turns out that testing the
null of compatibility against the
alternative that you're just consistent
already captures the sort of primary
difficulty the problem in a sense that
i'll uh make precise a bit later we're
used to situations like with pearson's
chi-squared test where the null
hypothesis parameter space is of lower
dimension than the alternative but here
we're testing
a full-dimensional subset so that's kind
of interesting
and there are various people uh in this
room like um yuting and and aditya who
who've shown very nice work recently
that when you're testing
for testing problems over the convex
polyhedra you need to understand the
sort of specific geometry of the of the
problem
so how might we think about uh improving
our tests well what we did in getting
the the critical value originally was we
just had a somewhat naive band where we
replaced this this sub over this this
complex
convex polyhedral set with uh this this
thing effectively over a hyper rectangle
and that's ignoring the the feasibility
constraints here and so what we're going
to try and do is to try to understand
this incompatibly index better and get
an improved test
okay this slide is maybe a little bit uh
complicated but it's
um
the the idea is we're trying to
understand that the um you know how many
what what does this this convex
polyhedral set look like how many facets
are there and it turns out that you can
you can realize this incompatibility
index not just as a supreme but over a
maximum over a certain number of uh
these functions fsls and and the number
is driven by the the number of what i
call essential facets of of this uh
minkowski sum of a com a marginal cone
and a consistent ball okay that's uh how
life is but essentially the the the the
upshot is is that this this capital f
number
uh is driving
uh the complexity of the problem and and
the kind of
separation that you would need in order
to be able to test incompatibility
so
uh the proposition says it certainly for
consistent sequences you can realize the
rfps in this way and more generally
you've got this expression of it as uh
the same thing as you had before but
then with this quantity added on
where where this is measuring in a total
variation sense how far from consistency
you are so you can think of having a
general uh family here which you're
projecting onto the set of consistent
sequences uh via this sort of total
variation distance and then you're
you're thinking about how far
you are with this this capital f here
okay so that motivates us to to uh get
an improved critical value and we've got
a very similar proposition to what we
had before with this improved critical
value
then uh you can um
you have the the same type one error
guarantee and a similar sort of uh power
guarantee that there's a constant such
that whenever you're separated in this
sense you've got power at least one
minus beta
well i'm not actually guaranteed
originally that i do better with this
new critical value although sort of
morally that's how i'm thinking of it
but you can definitely guarantee you're
going to do better if you take the
minimum of the critical values and both
the guarantees then hold so you've got
the type 1 error control and you've got
the power guarantees
so let's have an example uh in in our
kind of canonical
important example setting
a discrete case but where we've got an r
by s by two uh contingency table
then you can write down an explicit
expression for the rfps this is pretty
difficult to to write down i should not
to write down but to prove actually yes
actually typing it's not so difficult um
uh and then you can you can say exactly
what this this uh this minkowski sum is
um and because so this minkowski sum
you're writing as a maximum over all
subsets a of one up to r and all subset
b one one up to s
you don't have to worry about the empty
set you don't have to worry about the
full set so that tells you that you can
take this number of the this critical
number capital f to be 2 to the r minus
2 times 2 to the s minus 2 in in this
example
so the original test
uh
the kind of level at which you've got
non-trivial power involves the product
of r and s here whereas the improved
test reduces that to the sum of of r and
s okay so that's the sort of improvement
that you might uh get
by uh doing this more involved analysis
okay a very quick word about the the
proof here if you want to get a lower
bound uh on the so the rfps you get
inequality is getting going in both
directions to obtain this
you to get a lower bound you can just
think about the primal problem uh and
and you've just got to for each subset a
of one up to r e subset b of one up to s
you've got to choose a good sequence uh
of f s is
for the upper bound
uh you use the dual uh formulation that
i i showed and you can actually relate
this uh this computation to a maximal
two commodity flow so this is where
you're taking the two commodities one k
is one uh and ks2 from s1 and s2 to
these uh these sinks t1 and t2 um and
these kind of constraints uh govern the
capacity that of of what you can push
along each of these arrows um it turns
out that there's there's no analog of
the max flow min cut theorem for two
commodity flows so you have to work
quite hard to show that this is uh the
upper bound but but that's that's the
way we do it
okay so if we think about this in a in a
minimax
testing framework
so
if i want to have non-trivial power
uh in a uniform sense and i'm going to
need to separate myself from the null
hypothesis appropriately so this curly
ps of row just gives me this elbow room
that this row distance from from the
null
um
and the minimax separation rate
as risk at separation row uh there's
that's the the sum of the worst case
type one error and the worst case type
two error and you take the infimum over
all possible tests yeah
and the minimax testing radius is the
smallest row that gets this minimax risk
below a half okay so i can now augment
my uh my picture here where where this
row is showing me the the elbow room
that i've got and the question how small
can i can i get make this row and still
have this this non-trivial power
and uh sort of generalizing uh what i
mentioned before using the r improved
test we get this this upper bound on the
minimax testing radius of this form here
uh and then we can prove a corresponding
or almost matching mini max lower bound
uh which has just got these additional
log factors on the bottom so it's kind
of it it's uh
minimax optimal in the the r the s and
all the sample sizes up to the log
factors yeah okay so that's the benefit
of the improved test here
so uh what's quite interesting is each
time you want to construct a mini max
lower bound you've got to think about uh
constructing a finite subset of your uh
your sets and the way we do that gives
gives things that that are all
consistent so
we'd actually have the same lower bound
if we wanted to just test against
consistent alternatives here
not too far off um
okay so
um
in more complicated situations the uh
analytic expressions for the rfps can
get pretty difficult
and uh pretty quickly i mean that was
just with with uh cardinality of s is
three so we can often reduce it to
simpler problems here's a four
dimensional problem where where the the
variable four only appears in one of the
patterns variable five only appears in
one of the patterns and then it just
reduces back to this original
three-dimensional situation
another situation is where uh you've got
uh
the the variable um
one that appears in all of the patterns
and then you can kind of condition on it
to compute the rfps and that gives you
an explicit expression again
and finally uh in a situation where
you've got this kind of separation the
only thing that joins the two things
together is is this this uh this
diagonal here and then you can bound the
rfps between the maximum and the sum
so that reduces uh all the four
dimensional examples that down to you
can use a combination of those tricks to
get you down to just sort of five
examples and we can actually
fire some
analytic uh calculations and some uh
sort of
things from the computer output you can
actually work out exactly what rfps is
in all of the examples and and compute
expressions for the capital f which
grows fairly quickly
um
okay if you've got mixed and discrete
continuous variables if you've got
continuous variables we're just going to
bin them and if you've been them in an
appropriate way then you can apply our
discrete tests again and you can get an
upper bound on the
minimax testing radius again and it
depends on the smoothness of the
underlying functions
very quickly mention uh some uh
numerical results so uh i talked about
uh all our tests have having this finite
sample error control but it turns out
that uh in practice it may be a bit
conservative so you can do a monte carlo
test instead uh where in this dual
decomposition you you you can actually
extract a kind of closest compatible
sequence of marginal distributions
um and that is gives you something you
can bootstrap
from um
and so we did that and that gives you
these power functions in in black here
this is the three different ones give
you three different values of r here
and we're going to compare with with
fox's test the issue with fox's test is
it needed complete cases and we don't
have any complete cases here so we're
going to let it cheat
we're going to give it 200
complete cases the original sample sizes
were 200 for each of the bivariate
marginals we're going to give it 200
complete cases that we didn't have
access to
um
and actually we still do better in terms
of the power and the difference is kind
of getting bigger as ours increasing
here
um i think uh
from lisa's expression i should shut up
quite quickly um so here i i'll skip
over the this second example uh i will
uh wrap up here the the um
archive paper is available and the r
package i think uh went on crown a
couple of days ago
um and let me finish with uh saying
happy birthday peter it's a great
pleasure to be here i was sorry i
couldn't find a
photo with peter bartlett in here as
well
for one question
my question is quick first
really great work and my question is in
practice those ns the the sample size of
all the combinations are actually
random variables
would that affect any of the
theoretical results um
so actually in our lower bound we we
worked via a kind of poisson model for
further there was a sort of
possibilization trick where you do think
of random sample sizes
um
i i i we haven't done the theory in that
setting but i usually i mean if the the
sample sizes are independent of
uh of the data
my guess is it shouldn't make too much
of a difference yeah at least it should
hold conditionally right
okay thank you
um my question is in very high
dimensions um
[Music]
can you give like a lower bound on how
many observed entries i need to observe
to begin with
to be able to do something or
um
so
you you mean d is big i've got these
sort of very complicated missingness
patterns um we have these reductions
that can help you bound the the r of ps
in those cases
um
it is something you know i've only got
to maximize a linear function over a
complex set it's not the worst thing in
the world but trying to get analytic
expressions
that does get very complicated very very
quickly